OK, we have a voicemail number.
The number is 2 1 9 2, David P. That for people
who aren't able to translate that into numbers.
I want to mention that the number is 2 1 9
2 3 2 8 4 3 7.
You can call it anytime of day.
Here is a voicemail about an issue that also
I look for forward to opportunities to clarify
on other programs.
And it is about whether the U.S. is the worst
or not on our coronavirus response.
Take a listen.
We obviously we have the worst record of anybody.
We have one third of the deaths.
One third of the cases of the whole planet.
There's no doubt that we're the worst.
The world is absolutely no doubt.
OK, so here's where I am on this.
I. I don't know that the United States coronavirus
response has been the worst in the world.
And I've been careful not to say that it's
been one of the worst.
And if you say who who had the worst response
is slowest, most propagandistic suppressing
data, not testing, you know, all this different
stuff from the countries we know of that have
had a bunch of cases.
The United States is certainly on the list
of the worst.
Brazil is on the list of the worst.
India seems to be on that list.
Russia is on the list of the worst responses.
You know, I've heard anecdotally that Turkmenistan
had a terribly propagandistic totalitarian
response.
I just don't know enough about that.
And it's a very small country.
So, you know, it can be difficult sometimes
to glean everything we want to glean.
North Korea is thrown around.
But here's where I think we need to shift
the conversation on this.
Instead of arguing, is the U.S. the worst
or are we like fifth worst or tenth worst
or 20th worst?
What happened to American exceptionalism?
What happened to the people who say and believe
the U.S. should be the best that everything.
We certainly were not the best.
And we weren't second best or third best or
fourth best.
So let's shift the debate from are we really
the worst or just bad to why are we now using
that as a standard?
Since when is the standard in the United States
from those who subscribe to the idea of American
exceptionalism?
Since when is the standard?
Have we avoided being the worse?
The standard has always been.
Are we the best?
And no one can argue that we are the best.
Merely looking at South Korea, Taiwan, Japan,
Greece, you know, even a bunch of European
countries.
We're certainly not in the top 10.
I would argue we are in the worst 10 and all
of a sudden the debate is, are we are we the
worst?
That was never the debate.
If you believe in American exceptionalism,
do not let them hijack that conversation.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Producer Pat Ford will be joining me.
I also want to remind you, Monday, Memorial
Day, Monday, Memorial Day, we are doing a
one day membership kablooey, as I am calling
it, membership kablooey.
To take us back to the days of Warner Brothers
cartoons.
We will email everybody on our mailing list
on Monday with a one day coupon code, which
will give you an absolutely disgusting discount
off of membership.
So if you've been thinking of getting a membership
but haven't yet kind of waiting around for
that opportunity, Monday, Memorial Day is
the opportunity.
Be notified on Monday by signing up for our
mailing list at David Pakman dot com upper
right of the Web site.
You type in your email address.
I'm doing my typing motion, type in your email
address, and then Monday you will get that
email with this.
Just I mean, it's it's a vile coupon code,
quite frankly.
You would be shocked when you see it.
That does it for today.
On the bonus show, we will talk about UK citizens
being designated organ donors by default.
Very interesting story.
We will talk about some gyms starting to reopen
despite the fact that they aren't supposed
to yet.
I will give you an update on my gym.
I think we will hear from Pat about his gym.
And we also now are getting an apology from
Republican Georgia Governor Brian Kemp, because,
lo and behold, it's not just Florida.
The Georgia Web site incorrectly showed a
downward trend in Corona virus infections,
which was not accurate.
All of those stories and more on today's.
Bonus show, I'll see that.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.